The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: --afternoon.
Our main subject for today
is the fine structure
of atoms, when spin couples and
we bring spin into the picture.
And if time permits,
a Lamb shift.
But before I get
started, I just want
to finish up our topic of the
last class, which was helium.
And I said for many,
many years, we only
discussed single electron atoms,
but I introduced the helium
atom into the curriculum because
there are two aspects which
are really new and
which we can learn
from helium with a
more simple example.
One was the fact of
how the spin leads
to interactions even if nothing
couples directly to the spin.
And we discussed it last
class that because we
have singlet and triplet
states, they impose symmetry
or anti-symmetry onto the
spatial wave function.
And that makes a big
difference in the energy.
And it is sort of this
big Coulomb energy, which
is connected to spin,
which is actually
responsible for
magnetism in nature.
The second aspect, the
second new feature,
which is, of course,
also related to spin
is the presence of singlet
and triplet states.
And it gives me an
opportunity-- and this
was the last point we
discussed on Wednesday--
to raise the question,
what can cause
a transition from
triplet to singlet?
And at the end of
Wednesday's lecture,
we discussed the question,
what kind of couplings
would allow you want to drive
a transition from triplet
to singlet?
And at least based on the
clicker result, for most of you
the surprising answer was none.
Optical fields, not.
Rotating fields, not.
Within the approximation
we have so far-- namely,
just a Hamiltonian with
Coulomb interaction--
there is nothing
in the system which
connects the singlet
to the triplet world.
Well, there is a
very weak transition,
but the lifetime of
the triplet counts
it in helium, as I will
tell you a little bit later,
is 8,000 seconds.
It's extremely long life.
We have an extreme form
of metastability here.
Just an anecdote.
In the early days
when people learned
about the structure of atoms,
they looked at spectra.
And they never
found any line which
was connecting the singlet
states with the triplet states.
So it looked like if there were
two different forms of helium,
orthohelium and parahelium.
So people even
believed for a while
there were two kinds
of helium in nature
because they seemed to be
completely disconnected.
But as we know now,
of course, this simply
reflects the high
degree of metastability.
I want to emphasize
before I give you
the general framework and the
symmetry, spatial symmetry
and spin symmetry,
and we discuss all
that in exchange
symmetry-- I want
to emphasize what I said
at the end of the lecture
on Wednesday.
If you try to drive a transition
between singlet and triplet,
if you use a rotating magnetic
field, you can't do that.
Because a rotating magnetic
field couples to the total
spin.
It just makes the
total spin precess
around the axis of
the magnetic field.
But what the magnetic
field will never do
is break up the relative
angle between the two spins.
And in a triplet state,
the two spins are aligned.
In the singlet states,
they are anti-aligned.
And with a magnetic
field, you address
both spins simultaneously.
They precess together,
and you can never
change the angle
between the two.
So a singlet-triplet
transition really
requires that you go deeper.
You really have a handle on the
spins relative to each other.
Let me make a second comment
about the possibility
of doing an optical transition.
An optical transition, at least
in the dipole approximation,
has an electric field
acting on the dipole moment
of the electron.
There is no spin involved.
And let me sort of accentuate
it by saying, you should really
have in your mind that, at
least in dipole approximation,
the laser, the light, optical
beams, do not couple to spin.
The only couple to the spatial
part of the wave function.
And that has important
consequences.
In a lot of our research,
we do Raman transitions.
And with a Raman transition,
we do spin flips.
So how can a laser, or two
laser beams through a Raman
transition, flip the
spin if the laser is not
talking to the spin
degree of freedom?
Well, if you have
a Raman transition
and you excite a state which
has spin orbit coupling,
you excite the atom.
The spin does nothing
during the excitation.
But then in the
intermediate state,
spin and angular momentum may be
coupled by spin orbit coupling.
And the spin is
starting to precess
due to spin orbit coupling.
And then the spin
rotates, and then
the second leg of
the Raman transition
transfers the atoms back
to the ground state,
but now the spin has rotated.
But it is never the laser
which rotates the spin.
What should be immediately
clear from that
is if you try to
have a spin flip
Raman transition in an atom
which has no spin orbit
coupling don't
even look for that.
It doesn't exist.
Anyway, we just
encountered it here
and I want to tell
you that there is even
more general
consequences of that.
But let's now go back
to the helium atom
and look at the
spatial symmetry which
comes, of course,
because operators
are symmetric with regard
to the two electrons.
So what we have is we
have the total spin
is the sum of the spins of
electron 1 and electron 2.
And all spin operators--
the spin operator s
and its components-- are
symmetric against particle
exchange.
In other words, if
you couple to the spin
through a magnetic field, you
couple to the two electrons
symmetrically.
And therefore, you
have the selection
rule that only symmetric and
symmetric and anti-symmetric
and anti-symmetric
states couple.
Or, to express the same result
in different words, both
the spatial and the spin
symmetry, each of them
can be symmetric
and anti-symmetric.
Of course, the product of
them has to be anti-symmetric
because we're talking
about fermions.
So both of these symmetries
are good quantum numbers.
Or more formally, all
observables commute
with the particle
exchange operator.
So any arbitrary
observable commute.
So the commutator of the
particle exchange operator
vanishes.
OK.
But now, what is special
to the approximation
in which we have treated helium?
As long as wave
functions and operators
separate into spin-dependent
and space-dependent parts.
The wave function
had a spatial part,
and then we multiplied
with a spin wave function.
So the wave function
factor-wise separated
into a spin part
and a spatial part.
Also, the operators.
If you have operator
for total spin,
if you have operator
for dipole moment,
the operators are
either addressing
the spatial degree of freedom
or the spin degree of freedom.
So as long as this
is the case, we
have an even extended
conservation law
for both spin exchange for
an exchange of the particles
in the spatial domain
and in the spin domain.
So as long as wave
functions and operators
separate into spin and
space-dependent parts,
then the particle
exchange operator
can be regarded as the product
of an exchange operator which
only acts on the
spatial wave function
and on the spin part
of the wave function.
And both quantum numbers
for spin exchange--
symmetric/anti-symmetric--
and for exchange of particles
in the spatial part
of the wave function,
symmetric or anti-symmetric--
are conserved.
So often, we discuss
symmetries and the reason
why something is
conserved because then we
can think about
how to evaluate it.
Often, you can say,
conservation laws
are often written down just
as a way to think about.
How can we break them?
And in this case, we can
break this symmetries
which doesn't allow transitions
between singlet and triplet.
We have to break them to
get intercombination lines.
So in order to get a singlet
to triplet transition,
it's only possible
when we violate
the assumptions we
have just discussed.
And of course, an assumption was
that the wave function factors
into spin part and spatial part.
But when spin and
spatial wave functions
are mixed-- for
instance, by spin
orbit coupling-- then the
assumptions we have discussed
are no longer valid.
So what we need
is, for instance,
a mixing of spin and
spatial wave functions
by spin orbit coupling.
Well, as we will
learn later today,
spin orbit coupling
is, actually,
a relativistic effect.
It naturally arises
in the Dirac equation.
And it scales with-- the
nuclear charge is z to the 4.
So therefore in helium,
it is very, very weak.
Therefore, the triplet ground
state is extremely long-lived.
The lifetime in helium
is 8,000 seconds.
It's one of the most
longest-lived metastable states
you can imagine and which
you find in atomic physics.
Now, since spin orbit coupling
becomes rapidly stronger
with nuclear charge, you would
expect the metastable lifetime
to be much shorter
for the analogous
state in the other rare gases.
And indeed, the
other rare gasses
are on the order of 40 seconds.
You have other atoms where you
have singlet and triplet lines.
We need two electrons
and the two spins
can form singlet or triplet.
So that naturally
also happens in atoms
which are in the second
column of the periodic table.
Magnesium, calcium, strontium
have intercombination lines.
And they are actually very
relevant in current research
because these are candidates
for atomic clocks.
In those atoms--
magnesium, calcium,
strontium-- physics
is more complicated.
The line width is
typically kilohertz.
But that's probably
just what you want.
If the line width is kilohertz,
the lifetime is millisecond.
You still have a
matrix element that you
can drive the transition
and observe it.
For an atomic clock, you
don't want a transition
which is thousands of seconds
or half the age of the universe
because it's too weak to be
observed, to weak to be driven.
So intercombination
lines of kilohertz,
line widths of few
hundred Hertz or such,
are almost ideal for
optical atomic clocks.
Any questions?
So maybe then I should just
entertain you for a few minutes
about, how do you measure
an 8,000 second lifetime?
Well, there is a recent paper.
Insert Picture.
Desktop.
There's a recent
paper a few years ago,
Physical Review
Letters, determination
of the lifetime of
metastable helium.
Traditionally, people
have measured the lifetime
of metastable helium
in the following way.
No, they haven't observed
helium for 8,000 seconds.
Because if you have helium
in the metastable state,
maybe after a few seconds there
is some collisions-- collision
or deactivation.
8,000 seconds, you
would just have
many, many systematic effects.
What people did is
they put some atoms
into the metastable state,
measured the number of excited
atoms, and then-- maybe
during 100 milliseconds,
1 out of 80,000
atoms should decay.
And by determining what
small fraction of the atoms
has decayed, or how
many photons you observe
in 100 milliseconds divided
by the total number of atoms,
that's how you can
measure the lifetime.
Of course, the
problem is, yes, you
can measure the
number of photons.
But if you want to divide
by the number of atoms,
you have to know very accurately
how many atoms you have.
And this Australian group
used the very clever trick
to eliminate this uncertainty.
And this is as follows.
We have this extremely
long-lived 8,000 seconds
lifetime here.
And this is the transition.
But you can now excite the atom
to the triplet P0 state, which
is also sort of--
it's a triplet state.
Well, I assume because
it is a P state,
it has been orbit coupling.
The lifetime is-- well,
for an atom is very long.
Typically, atoms
decay in nanoseconds.
But this lifetime
is milliseconds.
So what they did is they
just excited all the atoms
with a strongly saturating laser
to the triplet P0 transition.
And then within a
few milliseconds,
all the atoms emitted.
And so all they had to
do is measure accurately
the ratio of the VUV photons
emitted by the triplet ground
state and by the
triplet P0 state.
And then the number
of atoms canceled out.
All they had to do is measure
the ratio of 2 VUV intensities.
So based on that research
now, we have higher accuracy
on the lifetime of
metastable helium.
The question is
when I said we have
to violate the above
assumptions to get
any decay between
singlet and triplet.
Metastable helium,
pretty much everything
you can think about
it is forbidden.
So for a long time,
people believed
it was a two-photon transition.
One-photon transition
was forbidden,
but a two-photon
transition was allowed.
We know now that
the decay path is
one photon in one transition.
Magnetic dipole transition.
If you don't know what M1 is, we
discuss it later in the course.
But you may find it interesting
that until rather recently,
it was not clear what
the decay path is.
Well, recently means
probably a few decades ago.
But for a long time,
it wasn't even clear
and the calculations
were not accurate enough
what was the mechanism by
which the metastable count
state of helium could decay.
When I prepared the class,
I wanted to sort of give you
a simple picture
and say, hey, it
is this mechanism which
causes the transition
from the triplet ground state
to the singlet ground state,
but I couldn't find
a simple operator.
It seems a little
bit more complicated.
The best I can tell you is
that the decay path requires
higher-order terms using the
Dirac equation with coupling
to the electromagnetic field.
Any questions?
Yes, Nancy.
AUDIENCE: In the measurement
of the lifetime of that state,
what is the limiting factor?
What makes this measurement
to be not more precise?
PROFESSOR: Here
is the reference.
I mean, this was a
highly-accurate measurement
for that it improved all
previous measurements.
What the current limit of
accuracy is, I don't remember.
But for instance, they had to
put all atoms into the excited
state or by strong saturation.
Of course, saturation
is never complete.
Maybe there's a
limitation to that.
Finally, you have to
measure the ratio of photons
emitted by that state and
emitted by that state.
Well, they're both
in the vacuum UV,
but you may have a
systematic effect
if your photo-detector has a
slightly different detection
efficiency for 58
nanometer and 62 nanometer.
Nothing is perfect,
but I really have
to refer you to the
reference for details.
OK.
So that's pretty
much what I wanted
to tell you about electronic
structure, the hydrogen
atom and special features
about the helium atom.
So we can now proceed from
electronic energies, which
were on the order of Rydberg.
Or remember atomic units, fine
structure constant squared
times rest mass of the electron.
So we've taken care
of those energies
and now we want to take
care of smaller corrections.
And what we discuss next is
the fine structure and the Lamb
shift.
So this is now the title of our
next chapter, Fine Structure
and Lamb Shift.
The fine structure energies
are alpha square times smaller
than the Rydberg.
So they're on the order of
alpha to the 4 mc squared.
And well, if I write that as
alpha square Rydberg, which
is the same, but it may--
this explains to you
why alpha is called the
fine structure constant.
People had learned about the
hydrogen spectrum, Bohr's model
and all that, and then they
found finer corrections.
And those finer
corrections were on a scale
alpha square times smaller.
And the constant
which appears here,
alpha, was called the
fine structure constant
because it described the
structure of the fine structure
corrections and the fine
structure splittings.
Of course if you want, you
can make the fine structure
constant already appear
for electronic energies.
But this simply
reflects that I have
used the rest mass
of the electron
as a reference energy,
which unless you want
to discuss fundamental
units doesn't make
any sense because c,
the speed of light,
it does not appear in
the electronic structure
as we discussed earlier.
So therefore, the fine
structure constant
does enter the picture only when
we now discuss fine structure
corrections, fine
structure splittings.
The Lamb shift, which
we will then discuss,
is even higher order.
It's alpha to the fifth.
But just to tell
you, the Lamb shift
is on the order of a gigahertz.
And you know that standard
precision in all of your labs
is now megahertz or better.
So the lamb shift, also
it's alpha to the fifth,
is a big effect on the scale
of how we understand and prove
the structure of atoms today.
OK, so let's talk about
the fine structure.
You will actually find
a complete discussion
of the fine structure
in several textbooks
on quantum mechanics--
[INAUDIBLE].
What I want to do here is
to have a careful discussion
of the physical origin and
provide a clear understanding
what is responsible
for the fine structure.
So if you just want to
get an accurate result,
there's only one
thing you have to do--
solve the Dirac equation.
The solution of the Dirac
equation for the hydrogen atom
gives us the
electronic structure,
the same as comes out
of the Bohr model,
but now including
the fine structure.
So it's nice.
It just comes out.
You don't have to put in the
spin of the electron by hand.
It comes out automatically.
But it also comes
out as a result
and you don't fully understand
what is the origin of that.
Because you've just
treated everything fully
relativistically.
So what I want to
show you here is
I want to show you
that we can distinguish
three contributions.
There are three
physical effects which
all come in at the level
alpha to the 4 mc squared.
One is relativistic corrections
to the kinetic energy.
The second one is
spin orbit coupling.
And then there is
a third one, which
goes by the name Darwin term.
And we can get this
physical insight
and obtain those
three terms separately
when we use what
is called the Pauli
approximation to
the Dirac equation.
If you do the so-called
Pauli approximation
to the Dirac
equation, you simply
expand the Dirac equation
in powers of v/c.
And then you get the Schrodinger
equations plus correction
terms.
And what you obtain
then is a Hamiltonian,
which is the rest energy,
which is constant;
the non-relativistic kinetic
energy, the Coulomb energy.
But then, we have
three more terms.
And these are the
three contributions
to the fine structure.
One is kinetic
energy is p squared,
but now there is a higher-order
relativistic contribution,
p to the 4.
Then, there is a term,
spin orbit coupling term.
And then there is
the third term,
which will we identify
as the Darwin term.
Laplace operator
e squared over r.
So we have a kinetic
energy correction.
We have a spin orbit correction
and we a Darwin term.
And what we want to do in
the next 45 minutes or so is
we want to look
at each of those.
Any questions?
The kinetic energy contribution
is the simple expansion.
You can get it from the
Pauli approximation.
You take the Dirac
creation and deal
with all the operators
in the Dirac equation
and do an expansion.
But you can also just
lean back and say, OK,
what is the kinetic energy?
And use the relativistic form
of the kinetic energy, which
is rest energy and pc squared.
The square root of it.
And if you say the kinetic
energy is the energy minus mc
squared, and then you take the
full relativistic expression
for the total energy minus 1.
And now you do a Taylor
expansion of the square root.
You find the non-relativistic
kinetic energy.
And the first correction term
with all the correct prefactors
is this one.
So this is the relativistic
energy correction
in the Pauli equation.
That's all we have to say.
The second term is
spin orbit interaction.
And as such, it is, I would say,
more interesting because it now
really addresses the spin.
So yes, the term comes
from the Dirac equation
and appears separately
as an identifiable term
if you do the
Pauli approximation
to the Dirac equation.
So I could just stop there and
say, here, that's what it is.
But I think it's insightful if
I re-derive this term for you
by using a physical picture.
What do we have to add to the
Schrodinger equation to get it?
What we have to add to the
Schrodinger equation is,
of course, we have to put in
that the electron has a spin.
The Dirac equation is
formulated in spin.
It's automatically formulated
for spin 1/2 particles.
But if you start with
the Schrodinger equation,
you can first write it down
for a spin-less particle,
and now you have to
add the spin by hand.
So we have to add to the
Schrodinger equation,
or to the Bohr
model, that we have
an electron with
an intrinsic spin.
And the spin will couple
to the rest of the world
because it has a magnetic
moment which is the g factor.
We'll talk about g factors
later in more detail.
The Bohr magneton
times the spin.
If you add it to the
Schrodinger equation,
we have to assume the
experimental value
or you can see the
value of which--
the approximate value
of the exact value
from the Dirac equation,
which is a g factor of 2.
So if you put in by hand
that the electron has a spin,
the spin is associated
with the magnetic moment.
Now we have a coupling
because an electron which
moves in the Coulomb
field of the nucleus
sees in its moving
frame a magnetic field.
And this magnetic field
couples to the spin.
So the moving electron "sees"
a motional magnetic field.
Well, you know when you
have an electric field
and you look at the-- you have
an electric field in one frame
and you have a second frame,
spatial relativity, which
moves with a velocity v.
Then, in the moving frame,
you observe a motional
magnetic field.
Well, our moving frame
is now the electron.
So that looks like coupling
to the Coulomb field,
but we can immediately
write it in a form
where we recognize
angular momentum.
So this is the Coulomb field.
And it involves now v cross r.
And v cross r is just minus L,
the orbital angular momentum.
So this is now our
motional magnetic field.
And then the spin couples to it
and we get spin orbit coupling.
By the way, an
equivalent picture
because you will
read about it or hear
about it is you can get the
magnetic field which couples
to the spin by simply
transforming the Coulomb
field into the frame
of the moving electron.
But there is a more naive
picture which is correct, too.
If you are in the
frame of the electron,
then the proton is
orbiting around you.
And the orbiting proton
is a ring current,
which creates a magnetic field.
And this magnetic
field is or it has
to be the same as
we just got by doing
the relativistic transformation
of the Coulomb field
into the frame of
the moving electron.
So therefore, let me
just leave some room
because I have to add something.
If we want the spin
orbit Hamiltonian,
it's now the magnetic moment
of the electron times this B
field.
And just collecting the terms,
e squared, h bar squared,
m squared, c squared,
1 over r cubed.
The magnetic moment is
proportional to s, the spin.
The motional B field
is proportional to L.
And now we have the famous
spin orbit coupling term.
OK, that would be too simple.
So we have to now
consider one more thing.
And this is-- I told you
that we can transform
the electric field into the
moving frame of the electron,
but those transformations
from one Lorentz
frame into the other are simple
when you go from one frame
to another and they move
with a constant velocity
relative to each other.
The electron is not moving
with a constant velocity.
It actually has a
constant acceleration
because it's on
a circular orbit.
So therefore, we have to use
the relativistic transformation
between coordinate frames.
And it is in textbooks
on spatial relativity.
What happens is if
you have-- if you
do relativistic transformations
between different moving
coordinate systems,
then you find
that if you have a velocity
like this, velocity like this,
and you do subsequent
transformations,
you are not just going
into a Lorentz frame which
has very solid and relativistic
addition of the velocities.
In addition, your
final Lorentz frame
is rotated against
the first frame.
So adding a number of velocities
which are not collinear--
and this is what we have
to do if the electron goes
in a circle.
We have to sort of
follow the electron,
follow different
velocities and do
relativistic transformations.
Several relativistic
Lorentz transformation
executed in sequence are not a
simple Lorentz transformation,
they are Lorentz
transformation plus rotation.
And that means that if
we go-- and the result
can be summarized as follows.
There is a rotational
angular velocity
which can be written as follows.
You see immediately
that this term
is 0 when a, acceleration,
and velocity are the same.
So if you have a moving frame
and you accelerate the moving
frame, you don't get
this term if everything
is in one dimension.
But if the acceleration
is not in one dimension--
and that's the case when the
electron goes on the circle,
you get an additional
contribution.
And if the acceleration
is constant,
you get-- and this is
on the left-hand side--
a constant angular velocity.
A precession velocity.
And the letter T indicates that
it's the Thomas precession.
Now, we have
learned-- and that's
nice to come back to the
beginning of this course.
We have discussed that if
you have a magnetic field,
we can go into a rotating
frame and the magnetic field
disappears.
Well now, due to
relativistic kinematics,
we have an additional rotation.
But using the same
argument we used
at the beginning of the course,
this additional rotation
corresponds to an
additional magnetic field.
So therefore, this precession
is identical to the effect
of an additional magnetic field.
So there is an
additional magnetic field
with the letter T, the
Thomas magnetic field.
Those magnetic fields are
related to the precession
frequency by the
gyromagnetic ratio.
And if we use the value for the
electron's gyromagnetic ratio--
and in addition, we use the
fact that the acceleration
term for this
relativistic kinematics
is nothing else than the
Coulomb acceleration,
then we find that the
Thomas magnetic field is
just minus 1/2 the
motional magnetic field we
derived earlier.
So therefore, if
we go back and want
to find an expression for
the spin orbit coupling,
we have to use the
magnetic field, which
is the sum of the two
contributions we discussed,
the motional contribution for--
as if the electron would move
in a linear way, plus
the Thomas precession
due to the rotational motion
due to relativistic kinematics.
And this will just
reduce the final result
by a factor of 1/2.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
Small one, what letter is the
gyromagnetic ratio denoted by?
PROFESSOR: Sorry
for the handwriting.
We have usually used
lowercase gamma.
And the e means the electron.
So gamma electron is
the gyromagnetic ratio
of the electron.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And then my other question, or
more substantively concern--
or confused, I guess.
I wasn't sure where
the h bar comes
from in the expression
for angular momentum.
One line up.
You go from v cross
r to h bar over mL.
And I wasn't sure where
the h bar came from.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
It now depends.
You're correct, angular
momentum is r cross
v. r cross v gives
angular momentum.
And because it's r cross
v and not v cross r,
the minus sign is
absorbed into it.
Now, the angular
momentum-- it depends now.
It's just purely definitional.
If you wanted, the
angular momentum
has eigenvalues of
L times L plus 1,
which are dimensionless, then
we have to account for h bar
explicitly.
So question is, do we want
the angular momentum operator
to have this kind of
integer, or L times L plus 1?
Yeah.
This integer spectrum,
or do we want
to measure-- or, do we
want to use operators
which have units of h bar?
That's where the
h bar comes from.
Other questions?
OK.
So this is spin orbit coupling.
Finally, the last contribution
to the fine structure
is the Darwin term.
The Darwin term is
sort of peculiar,
but there is sort of
an intuitive picture
in which I can derive it.
Well, it starts by saying
that an electron-- well, we
know an electron is, as far
as we know, a point object.
But in order to derive
the Darwin term,
we assume that the
electron is not
arbitrarily
accurately localized,
but it is smeared out.
And you may remember
when I discussed
fundamental units and the
fine structure constant alpha,
and I told you that the
fact that alpha is small
leads to the fact
that people say
electromagnetic
interactions are weak.
I discussed with
you that if you want
to do single-particle physics
and do single-particle pictures
and single-particle
equations, you
can never assume that a
particle is localized better
than its Compton wavelengths.
If you would localize
the particle better
than the Compton
wavelengths, it would
have a momentum
uncertainty, which
would lead to an energy
is larger than its rest mass.
And you get into quantum field
theory and pair production.
So at some point,
you have to be aware
that single-particle
pictures break down
when you assume a
localization of particles
better than the
Compton wavelengths.
So therefore-- and
I'm waving my hands
because it's a
hand-waving argument.
But we can derive
the Darwin term
by assuming that the electron
is sort of smeared out
over a dimension.
And this dimension can only
be the Compton wavelengths,
which is h bar over mc.
And there is a nice
German word for it,
how you can imagine that
the electron is smeared out.
It goes by the word
[SPEAKING GERMAN].
I think the German word is much
nicer than its translation,
which is trembling motion.
So at least in this
picture you assume
that the electron is
sort of smeared out.
It's not because the
electron has a size.
It just trembles.
It just trembles and that leads
to a smear-out over the Compton
wavelengths.
But that implies now that
if this trembling motion is
sufficiently fast, we should not
use in our Schrodinger equation
the Coulomb potential.
You should use the Coulomb
potential which is spatially
averaged over the
Compton wavelengths.
So therefore, the
phenomenological derivation
of the Darwin term goes by
replacing the Coulomb potential
in the Schrodinger equation by
the spatially-averaged Coulomb
potential.
So let me now derive
what this means.
So if we assume there is a
very small displacement s,
now we can take the
Coulomb potential
and expand it into its Coulomb
potential plus derivative times
s plus the second-order
Taylor expansion
the xi, the xj component.
And then we need the
second-order derivative xi
xj of the Coulomb potential.
So the correction is now--
well, if you ever reach it
in an isotropic way,
the gradient term,
a linear term
doesn't contribute.
It just averages to 0.
So the leading correction
comes from the curvature term.
So therefore, we have to take
the curvature or the Laplacian
of the Coulomb potential.
The scale of sx squared,
sy squared, sz squared
is the Compton
wavelength squared.
And well, maybe I'm taking
the argument of the Compton
wavelengths now too literally.
But at least if I want to
carry it through, sx squared,
sy squared, sz squared, each
of them 1/3 of s absolute value
squared.
So if I now use the
Coulomb potential,
I obtain the result where I
have the Laplacian of 1/r.
And as you, of course,
know is the 1/r function
has a non-vanishing
Laplacian only at the origin.
So therefore, the
correction is only valid
for s electrons which have
a non-vanishing probability
to feel the origin of
the Coulomb potential.
OK, I did a lot of
hand-waving here.
And yes, those
factors of 1/2 are
the fact that the electron is
smeared out over the Compton
radius and maybe prefactors.
But OK, this is the
physical picture.
You can get an exact
result by simply taking
the Dirac equation, doing the
non-relativistic approximation,
and the term which appears
in the Pauli equation
is actually the same.
The only thing
which is different
is that the
prefactor is not 1/6.
The exact prefactor is 1/8.
So the exact results
actually validates
that the physical
picture we have used
is at least a reasonable
approximation.
OK, so we have now--
let us summarize.
For the fine structure, we
have three different terms.
And they all have a
different signature.
We have the relativistic
kinetic energy correction,
we have the spin orbit coupling,
and we have the Darwin term.
We can now ask, which term
contributes for an s electron?
Well, relative kinetic
energy, of course.
The Darwin term is
only for s electrons.
LS does not contribute because
an s electron has L equal 0.
So if we go to p and d states,
to states with finite angular
momentum, then we get
contribution of LS.
We always get a relativistic
kinetic energy contribution.
But for finite angular momentum,
we don't have the Darwin term.
And finally, we
can also classify
those different contribution
by asking, what is the sign?
Do those corrections lower
or increase the total energy?
Well, the Darwin term
reduces the binding energy
because it sort of
takes a cusp away
from the Coulomb interaction.
The kinetic energy has the
opposite sign and spin orbit
coupling is L dot S. And S can
be parallel or anti-parallel
to L. So therefore, the
spin orbit interaction has
plus or minus sign.
Any questions about
those three terms?
OK.
The fact that we
have spin and we
have spin orbit interaction
means that the spin orbit
interaction, L dot S is
not diagonal in L or S.
So what we have to do is
we have to introduce now
the total angular momentum
J. And since L plus S squared
equals J squared, we
can write the product LS
as 1/2 J squared minus L
squared minus S squared.
So therefore, the LS interaction
is diagonal in the J basis.
So if you couple L and S to J
a given state of the operator
J has a definite value for LS.
OK.
Let's put in things together.
So at the beginning
of this class,
we started out with
a hydrogen atom
where-- let me just focus on
n equals 2, where we had n
equals 2.
All n equals 2 states have
the same energy, that's
what comes out of the
non-relativistic Schrodinger
equation with a
Coulomb potential.
And that means we had a
degeneracy for the 2p 1/2,
for the 2p 3/2 and
the 2s 1/2 state.
If you now put in spin
orbit interaction, well,
nothing of course happens
to the s 1/2 state
because it has no
orbital angular momentum.
And then in the P
3/2 state, L equals
1, 1 unit of orbital angular
momentum, and the spin aligned.
In the p 1/2 state,
they are anti-aligned.
So therefore, the two
terms have opposite shifts.
So the p 3/2 state is shifted
up and the p 1/2 state
is shifted down.
But then in the
second step, we want
to add in now the two
other contributions
to the fine structure, the
kinetic and the Darwin term.
And then, something happens
which is really remarkable.
We have split the three levels.
We have lifted the degeneracy
between the three levels.
But if you now add the
kinetic and the Darwin term,
it turns out that the s
1/2 and the p 1/2 state
become exactly degenerate again.
So there is still a
degeneracy in the spectrum.
If we would use a
non-relativistic approach
and derive the Darwin
term, the spin orbit
term, and the relativistic
correction separately,
there would be no reason.
It would just look like a
freak accident in nature
that those two levels
come out equal.
However, it's not
a freak accident.
It's the symmetry of
the Dirac equation.
So all those corrections
have a deep connection
in relativistic physics.
And relativistic physics
preserves the degeneracy in J.
So let me write that down.
So the fine structure does
not lift the degeneracy
between s 1/2 and p 1/2.
It turns out that when we
use the Dirac equation,
we can get an exact expression
for the fine structure
into the [INAUDIBLE].
And it's a principal
quantum number.
And then the fine structure only
depends on J and not on L and S
separately.
So that tells us that
eventually the spin
of the electron and
the fine structure
really have deep origins
in the relativistic nature
of the underlying physics.
Any questions about
fine structure?
Let me get a white
page and draw you
sort of an energy-level diagram,
put in a few numbers which then
leads us to the discussion
of the Lamb shift.
So we have hydrogenic
energy levels with n
equals 1 and n equals 2.
We have s states and
we have p states.
We just discussed the fine
structure which shifts down
the energy of all those levels
in the ground-- I mentioned
that the fine structure is
alpha to the 4 mc squared.
And for the ground state,
the prefector is minus 1/8.
And this is the one-- the
term designation is s 1/2.
Here, we get the 2s 1/2 level
and the shift is minus 5/128
in the same unit alpha
to the 4 mc squared.
We have the exact
degeneracy between the s 1/2
and the 2p 1/2 state.
Whereas, the p 3/2 state is
only shifted by minus 1/128.
To put in some numbers
in electron volt,
the fine structure in the ground
state is on the order of 10
to the minus 4 electron volt.
The splitting here, which is
the fine structure splitting
of the p 1/2 and the
p 3/2 state is 4 times
10 to the minus 5 electron volt.
So that means at the level of
10 to the minus 4 electron volt,
we understand atomic structure.
Well, but we want to go further.
And the next thing
we want to discuss
is that-- what is the exact
degeneracy between s 1/2
and p 1/2 is actually lifted
when we introduce photons.
When we allow the
electrons to couple
to the electromagnetic
field, that's
QED, Quantum Electrodynamics.
And that introduces the
Lamb shift, which in the n
equals 2 state is
10 to the minus 6
electron volt, which is
approximately 1 gigahertz.
And that's what we
want to derive next.
Since I have this
nice, level diagram
I want to also indicate to
you what we do next week.
And this is when we
bring in the proton.
So far we have said
there is a point charge,
but the proton is a particle
which has finite size.
But also, it has finite
angular momentum.
And then we have to
bring in fine structure.
And we will learn
that the s 1/2 ground
state splits into two
hyperfine components.
And the hyperfine structure
will be at a similar energy
scale as the Lamb shift.
And actually, this fine
structure splitting
is the famous 14--
it's about 1 gigahertz.
It's the famous
1,420 megahertz line,
which everybody who does
astrophysics knows about it.
It's also, in other units,
the famous hydrogen measure,
which has an emission
line at 21 centimeter.
Anyway, this is
sort of our roadmap.
We have taken care of
everything down to 10
to the minus 5 electron volts.
And now we want to proceed
today and in the next lecture
to 10 to the minus 6.
First, the Lamb shift, where
we are still holding on
that the nucleus is a point
charge, has no structure.
Then, we have done
everything we can do.
What happens in the Coulomb
field of a point charge?
We have the spin
of the electron.
We have QED.
We have done everything.
And then what remains is to put
in the structure of the proton,
which will lead us to
hyperfine structure.
Any question?
OK, then let's get started
with the Lamb shift.
Just to make sure that
you're not getting confused,
there is also a lamp shift.
This is actually an
old-fashioned word
for an AC Stark effect.
People in the '50s
and '60s found
that spectral lines
in a mercury discharge
shifted when you took
another mercury lamp
and illuminated the mercury with
a strong light of another lamp.
So a lamp shift
is simply a shift
due to the electromagnetic
radiation emitted by a lamp.
But that's what we
are talking about.
We want to talk about
the Lamb shift, which
is named after Willis Lamb,
who received the Nobel
Prize for the discovery that
the 2s 1/2 and the 2p 1/2
level in hydrogen
are not degenerate.
And he wouldn't have
gotten the Nobel Prize
if it would have been
simply of one little feature
in the spectrum of hydrogen.
But the discovery of this
lifting of the degeneracy
actually opened up the
field for the development
of quantum electrodynamics.
So this was the
experimental discovery
which led to quantum
electrodynamics.
And this is why it's a
very famous effect done
by a now very famous
man, Willis Lamb.
The full description of the
Lamb shift would require QED.
And later in this course,
we are developing the tools
to do that.
I don't want to do it here.
I want to give you a simplified
physical picture which actually
nicely relates the Lamb shift
to the Darwin term which
we have just discussed.
But sort of just in full
disclosure, what you have to do
is, if you fully quantize
the electromagnetic field,
you have a vector
potential which
describes the vacuum mode.
And you have a vector
potential, which
is the operator of the
fully-quantized field.
And if you now carry out
second-order perturbation
theory in this operator A of
the quantized electromagnetic
field.
In other words, you allow
the atom or the electron
in the atom to couple to all
the empty modes of the vacuum,
then you obtain the Lamb
shift in its full beauty.
This is discussed nicely in
"Atom Photon Interaction"
by Claude
Cohen-Tannoudji, et al.
So this is the nature.
The nature of the Lamb
shift is the coupling
to the vacuum modes.
But I want to capture that now
in a semi-classical picture.
So the picture I
am presenting here
is due to Welton
and Viki Weisskopf.
And yes, it has to address
the nature of the Lamb shift.
And this is the coupling of
the electron to the vacuum,
but the vacuum is not empty.
The vacuum is filled
with a zero point
energy of the
electromagnetic field.
What we need is that we
have electromagnetic modes
and they have a
zero point energy.
And each mode has a zero
point energy of h bar omega.
And maybe before I do
any equations, which
will take five minutes
and about one page,
I should just give you
the physical picture.
I think it's much clearer
to understand that.
So the moment each
mode has an energy,
then each mode has a
fluctuating electric field.
Now what we have
to do is we have
to multiply the contribution--
the energy of each mode
by the density of modes.
We have to sum over all modes.
But then in the end what
we get is an expression
for the fluctuating
electric field.
And remember, in
the Darwin term,
we assumed that the electron
is trembling by itself
and is smeared out over
the Compton wavelengths.
But now in addition to
its own trembling motion,
the electron is now shaken
by the electric field
of the vacuum.
And this leads to an
additional smear out.
And this is the Lamb shift.
So that's what we
want to put together.
So we want to calculate
an additional contribution
to a trembling motion
of the electron.
But this time, it is driven
by the electric field which
persists even in the vacuum.
So that's the Lamb shift.
OK, so it's 1/2 h
bar omega per mode.
We have to use the
density of modes.
And the density is, of
course, per unit volume
and frequency interval.
So we have a density.
mu is the frequency
and you probably
remember that the density of
modes scales with frequency
squared.
So that means the density
of the zero point energy
is 1/2 h mu per mode
times the mode density.
And this means it scales
now with mu cubed,
the frequency cubed.
And since we want
to introduce now
the electric field, the
[INAUDIBLE] electric field.
If you go from electric
field to energy,
the energy density
of the electric field
is proportional to e Squared.
So therefore, what we
derive from this picture
that the vacuum is filled with
an oscillating electric field.
And this oscillating
electric field
is characterized by a value, by
a spectral density E squared,
which is proportional
to mu cubed.
And if I collect the constants
h and speed of light, it's this.
So the question is, what
does this electric field
do to the electron?
Well, let's not discuss the
electron in a hydrogenic orbit.
Let's, rather, discuss
in a simplified picture,
what is the effect of such
a field on a free electron?
And we will later discuss that
for very high-frequencies,
an electron can be
regarded as free.
So therefore, if s is the
coordinate of the electron,
and you drive it with an
oscillating electric field
at frequency mu, then the
driven amplitude of the electron
is the electric field.
I just want to make sure we
keep track of the powers of mu.
Because we take the
second-derivative acceleration,
we get two powers of mu.
So we have an extra
mu squared term.
Of course, the phase
is random, so we're not
interested in the amplitude.
We are interested in sort
of an average amplitude
square or an RMS
amplitude, which
is-- the amplitude
was proportional
to the electric field.
The amplitude squared is
proportional to the square
of the electric field.
And our prefactor
involves now mu to the 4.
Just in the equation
at the top, we
had an expression for
the spectral density
of the electric field E
squared which goes mu cubed.
So that means now that
the spectral density
of the motion of the electron
s mu squared goes as 1 over mu.
And yup, e squared h bar pi
squared m squared e cubed.
And now, yes, I wanted to
do it in the same lecture
as the Darwin term
because we know
that there was a change to the
Coulomb potential in the Darwin
term which came because the
electron was smeared out
over an area s squared.
Remember, this was the
Compton [INAUDIBLE] squared.
And it involved the Laplacian of
the potential Taylor expansion
second order, second
derivative in three dimension
is the Laplacian.
And for the Coulomb
potential, this
is non-vanishing, of
course, only at the origin.
So therefore, we
have now executed
what I discussed before.
We calculated the
sort of displacement
of the free electron
driven by the vacuum
fluctuations of
the electric field.
And these smear
out of the electron
leads to a change of the-- of
the average Coulomb potential.
We average the Coulomb
potential over the first motion
of the electron.
And that means now that we
get a change of the binding
energy of the electron, which
is nothing else in perturbation
theory than the matrix element
of the perturbation operator.
But this perturbation
operator was a delta function.
And we have the prefactor,
which is the spectral density
of the displacement
s mu squared.
So let's wrap up.
So we know because of
the delta function,
it only affects s electrons.
And remember I discussed
at great lengths
that for an electron with
principal quantum number n,
the probability to be at
the center was n cubed.
So here again, we have
the n cubed factor,
which we discussed for the
hydrogenic wave function.
And the only thing which is
non non-trivial we have to do
is we have to integrate
over all modes mu.
So therefore, what we
had so far was the shift
caused by one frequency of
the electromagnetic spectrum.
But now we have to integrate
over all frequencies.
So what we have to do is-- our
spectrum s squared goes as 1
over mu.
And if you integrate 1 over
mu over all frequencies,
you get a logarithm.
You get logarithmic divergences.
So therefore, our result is--
and I'm using now atomic units,
alpha cubed z to the
4 the n cubed factor.
Everything is in
units of atomic units.
The atomic unit of energy
is 1 Hartree or 2 Rydberg.
But the factor which
is now non-trivial
is from the logarithm,
we integrate.
And we have divergences
at both ends.
So we need a cutoff at a minimum
and at a maximum frequency.
For the maximum
frequency-- well,
there is a natural cutoff.
We have to cutoff at the
rest energy of the electron,
otherwise we are no longer
doing single-particle theory.
And the cutoff, the lower
cutoff, is the following.
We have used a picture
here for free electron,
but we can regard the
orbiting electron only as
a free electron on
time scales which
are much faster than
one orbital period.
So therefore, we have
to use as a lower cutoff
the frequency of the
orbiting electron, which
is z squared n cubed
in atomic units.
So with that, then I should
stop because time is over.
We have a little
bit hand-wavingly,
but it appears in
a logarithm anyway.
We have gotten for the ratio of
the upper and the lower cutoff
an expression which is n cubed
over z squared times alpha
squared.
And if we apply it
to s state where
it's most important
because there
is the degeneracy between p
1/2 and p 3/2 to be lifted,
we get a result that
the energy splitting is
now-- and with the
assumptions we have made,
the logarithm is 8 over
a squared, alpha squared.
And from that, we
would have derived
a Lamb shift of 1,600 megahertz.
Well, the exact value
is 1,058 megahertz.
I'm missing five minutes to
discuss the result in terms
of vacuum polarization,
but that's
something we do on Monday.
Any quick question?
OK, great.
See you on Monday.